étrangère dans nos démocraties elles se
pose elle a été posée par Nathalie
Goulay à l'instant elle se pose bien sûr
aussi avec la question du scandale
européen qui est en train de secouer le
Parlement européen avec une ingérence
avec un qui proviendrait du Qatar votre
réaction André gatelin à cette situation
ce scandale il fait mal aujourd'hui aux
institutions européennes il fait mal et
en même temps il m'étonne pas j'ai
travaillé au Parlement européen vous
savez quand vous arrivez dans le hall du
Parlement européen et que un grand
constructeur automobile en l'occurrence
allemand mais ça pourrait être un autre
à son modèle exposé j'ai l'impression
d'être au Salon de l'automobile
c'est-à-dire que
on a fait on cite Parlement européen
comme un exemple à décoller liste de
lobbyiste une fois que vous êtes sur que
c'est plus transparent c'est pas le cas
les gens sont bourrés au Parlement
européen parce que il y a tout les
limonadiers fournisseurs de bière qui
payent des pots à tout le monde et vous
terminez
la semaine comme ça je le dis il faut
être quand même extrêmement vigilant
j'aime je défends le Parlement européen
je trouve que c'est un endroit où on dit
souvent haut et fort ce que les
gouvernements n'osent pas dire surtout
parce que le Parlement européen n'a pas
beaucoup de pouvoir législatifs donc il
va des résolutions sur les droits de
l'homme sur les libertés qui sont
absolument formidables dès qu'on passe
au niveau exécutif dans les institutions
européennes ou au niveau des des États
membres là tout fout le camp donc je dis
là il faut être prudent au-delà oui des
phénomènes de corruption mais il y en a
je suis membre de l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe on
a dû exclure une dizaine de membres
c'était le caviarget il y a un pays qui
s'appelle l'Azerbaïdjan qui en est
membre et qui arrosait les gens et
aujourd'hui nous sommes soumis à des
obligations de déclaration tous les ans
et de certification et il y a que comme
ça que ça peut fonctionner c'est encore
plus compliqué dans une instance
internationale ou multiplie ce soit
l'Union européenne nous le conseille de
l'Europe parce que vous avez des gens
qui ont des
pratiquesment en France on ne peut il y
a que les personnes physiques qui
peuvent financer des campagnes
électorales et c'est limitées à 7500
euros par an par personne c'est déjà
beaucoup en Allemagne ou dans d'autres
pays les entreprises peuvent
subventionner pourquoi croyez-vous que
l'Allemagne s'est mis points et humains
liés avec la Russie pour son énergie et
la Chine pense en commerce parce que les
industriels
allemands ont financé pendant des années
aussi bien là c'est sous CD ou que le
Parti social-démocrate donc il fallait
rien dire donc vous voyez il y a un
moment l'argent en politique doit être
très strictement contrôlé c'est déjà la
base contre la corruption